wait where are my eggs in my
belly now get a move on it's Heist time
I love
Halloween all right how about this I
will bet you that by midnight tonight I
can steal the metal of Valor from your
office are you in my ceiling
balda no so what's the plan you wait for
me to leave my office lower yourself
down take my medal and win the bet who
are you talking to there's no one up
here are you still there Captain are you
still there I
can't ow how's the unwinable BET going
well on the one hand I fell through the
ceiling and onto a pencil but on the
other hand I also badly bruised my brain
excuse me one
second nice costume
Peralta no Peralta here just a normal
janitor pushing trash
around
I'm going to have to call you
back wait stop scratching me we're
supposed to be a team well I was going
to ask you to tell the captain that I
brought in Royal babies for Diaz but I'm
sure he already knows since he's always
one step ahead of me hey Captain Hal can
you come out here for one
[Music]
sec you need something br
yes I do hit it Royal
[Music]
babies you have 5 minutes into your
deadline and here you are handcuff to a
table in a locked room which is
precisely where I planned on
being come out of there as it turns out
our friend Rosa is great at picking
locks what about the pigeons oh the gray
pigeons they were a red herring thank
you their only purpose was to draw you
into the copy room while two members of
my team broke into your locked office as
you walked over here Charles awkwardly
stuffed himself through your window and
opened your safe we had the four numbers
of your code which meant there were 24
possible combinations for Charles to try
that could take up to 4 minutes which is
why I really dragged out this
explanation I mean really stretched it I
don't know if you noticed but there were
times where I was like what am I even
talking about game over
Captain check me I think you mean
Checkmate Jake Peralta is an amazing
detective/genius
now if you'll excuse me I have some
paperwork to
do all right but now it's time for round
two of our Halloween bet this year I
believe I'll make things more difficult
for myself let's say what I'll steal the
watch right off your wrist I was behind
the
door the actual theft will be pulled off
by Dan mccy
AKA
fingers how you
[Music]
doing monitor
now sir sir I'm so sorry I just wanted
somebody to check my son's candy please
let me help you
up on behalf of the 99 I apologize here
we
go weird it's just a
note thanks for the watch I want $300
absolutely no problem whatever you need
shake your car no ow glass no syringe
Jak you parked in front of a hydrant
stupid fire department excuse me shoess
cop coming
through Charles where are you come on I
won't stop the party but I do need the
bus all
right I can still still win this bet I
can still
win no no
no free don't
move oh my God there is a tiny chance I
may not win this B it turns out the
criminal I hired to lift your watch was
not trustworthy and I ended up
Contracting tuberculosis of the foot and
subsequently losing your death watch my
watch is right here no I made a switch
that's a fake no
this one's a fake what I knew you would
try to take something important to me
during the year I drew your attention to
my watch mccre stole my watch and then
replaced it with a replica and while you
celebrated mccre put my watch back in my
pocket the watch never left my
person I can see that you're enjoying
this so how'd you convince the whole
Squad to betray me what did you offer
them I asked them if they wanted to
embarrass you and they instantly said
yes not going to lie that turns me on a
little
[Applause]
bit very well Captain Raymond Holt you
are an amazing police captain SL genius
Halloween Heist 3 The Heist ining
tagline this year we both attempt to
steal the same object instead of Jake
attempting to steal one from me I gave
you one direction on the tagline Snappy
but yes we will be attempting to steal
the same item this I choose Terry
okay bronze over brains all right I take
Charles I get it close friend I pick
Gina Gina I take Rosa what you really
hurt my feelings by leaving me off your
team oh I had no idea you felt that way
well it doesn't feel great to be left
out right totally I get it I'm sorry
Captain Hol what why are you yelling at
my boobs because that's where the camera
is Jake really pissed me off and I want
to help you take him down well that's an
intriguing proposition you certainly
could be useful thank you to
Jake I gotcha Peralta you're not fooling
anyone why does everyone think that's
where a camera would be because the
cleavage cloaks the camera with its
curves all right smile three two one
cheese very good great you guys let's go
find
daddy what's going on oh look he's got
the crown and he's headed to the break
room he dumped it in the trash did he go
back and get it nope janitor came in and
took it but which janitor looks like I'm
going to have to
squint his name is Al Charles I need
your butt meet me downstairs Alpha Team
this is the golden Sparrow rendevu at
Drop Zone Yankee where'd you come with
all those code names I'll get the
elevator crap looks like we're taking
the stairs you're looking for Al of
course we're looking for Al you imbecile
are you Al the janitor nope I'm your
worst
nightmare Amy Santiago while Scully
gracefully moved the witch I got into
character H triggered the witch which
brought Jake into the room and I threw
the crown in the trash can exactly as I
planned then I sent you all here placed
an out of order sign on the perfectly
functional elevator made you all walk up
31 flights of stairs and vomit twice
actually it was four times if you count
all the stairwell stuff you thought I
was just Holt Lackey and you thought I
was just Jake girlfriend well I'm my own
person capable of making my own
decisions and I decided to humiliate you
both well you did I believe there's
something else you both need to say
gladly Amy Santiago is an amazing
detective/genius it's time for round
four of the Halloween
[Music]
High we'll be playing for this a plaque
that reads the ultimate detective/genius
blacking the Kaboodle I select Charles
Bole what what what's the matter Peralta
were you expecting to have Detective Bo
on your team I had absolutely nothing
planned for Charles I totally planned
everything for Charles this is a
nightmare I can do anything Charles can
except look exactly like the body devil
I got for him hi as expected all eyes
are on the Kaboodle it's go time now
Gina
whoopsie bill but you got to stand like
me I'm kind of like a young Brando voila
of course you could break the window but
you would never knowingly destroy
government property with you well
misread that one cheetah skate skate
like the
wind so
suck oh Gina are you okay it's cool I
got a pizza here for raymen Holt I have
a pizza here for Raymond Holt I have a
pizza here for Raymond H who do you work
for a pizza
man everyone with a pizza get out of
[Music]
here
the Kaboodle the Kaboodle the cble
Dale was the operation a
success you tell me this is where I
stash a few cigarettes on the rare
occasion that I need a
puff oh that's a plaque it's hidden in
the evidence room the box Mark cold
cases 1972 thanks bud something strange
is a foot which of these are real black
lights what the hell look at the plaques
are heists dumb
are heists dumb of course not that was a
stupid question no Jake it says heists
are
dumb
Carri sup
losers 3 weeks ago Captain Hol asked me
to order a plaque that read the ultimate
detective SL denius I did it and I
ordered three copies and the next phase
of my plan a quote and quote skating
accident but you knocked out your two
front teeth false teeth fake blood every
time one of you stole a plaque I've
replaced it with a fake I think I've
proved a point and that's why we're
changing the name of the plaque forever
to what Gina lanetti is the ultimate
human SL genius thank
you it's Heist time this year we compete
for the most elegant and Regal of all
prizes a championship
cumberbon the belt is in place Whoever
has it at midnight will be declared
what's going on what's Happening I can't
see silence it's gone the cover bun is
gone Gina I should have known it was you
they fell for it ah and right on time
here's Bill here's the belt ah She's a
Beauty ow Charles what are you doing the
hardest thing I've ever done betraying
you Bill the belt okay Serge lift up the
super heavy thing that no one else is
strong enough to
lift
why you sweating well if I'm sweating as
you CLA it's because I was watching an
exciting video on the net
really this isn't the championship cbond
this is some common
cbond you're not cheddar this just some
common who took
cheddar bless you she sneezed dog
allergies which means that Amy took
cheddar
where is my dog aren't you standing
right next to him this please stop
hello of Amy
[Music]
who I don't know what's going on you see
Jake I'm always going to be one step
ahead of you you've lost the ability to
surprise me you're just plain boring
again weird take on a very loving
relationship and it's midnight so I
guess I'm an amazing human SL genius
yeah although
you might want to read the inscription
on that there belill why oh no what does
it say Amy Santiago will you marry
me
surprise Jak and Amy to Jak and Amy
great stuff great stuff so since peral
altered the cumber bun no one really won
the heist this year is that what
everyone's thinking Captain right right
sorry not the time I'm so happy for you
both technically there was no winner
continue Heist Heist it's a s De Mayo
Heist a s De Mayo Heist makes just as
much sense as Halloween let's do it does
anyone have anything valuable on them
maybe some jewelry I have a medical
alert bracelet that tells people my name
and address in case I have a brain
collapse perfect this year's Champion
will be whoever is in possession of
scully's very upsetting bracelet at
midnight tonight Best Day
Ever there now they're locked in arrange
your Affairs The Heist begins in 5
minutes 5 minutes but this whole thing
was so last second I don't even have any
plans or supplies I have so many plans
and supplies allow me to introduce you
to other
Scully hi I'm Merl will tell Jake you
are pregnant with this child what I'm
not pregnant here's a positive pregnancy
test and a sonogram of your feeders
haral is going for the
bracelet what the hell was that that
Fitbit I gave you at Christmas I
modified it into a taser now if you'll
excuse me I'm going to hide the old
bracelet and win me this Heist don't you
mean win us this Heist oh Terrence
unfortunately I do
not should help I'm not touching
this there's no bracelet in his pocket
what there should be where'd it
go Shalom
[Music]
partner where's this going all the way
to Trenton take your time Jak oh Terry
you betrayed me as well you betrayed me
first you TR me Rosa and then you shi me
to New Jersey who has the bracelet now
Santiago yeah take that Amy do not make
me taste you again no no no don't I'm
pregnant what ah she's making it up the
pregnancy scan was my idea no hey enough
you all suck oh no my voice command
Terry look
out what is happening you all
[Music]
suck I knew you'd suggest a heist as a
distraction for my lieutenant exam then
all I had to do was sit back and watch
watch as everyone took things way too
far once my fake concussion was on
display I created the perfect
distraction for my partner to do his
job cheddar you duplicitous to
Terry Jeffords the ultimate human being
SL genius nice work Lieutenant ladies
and gentlemen welcome to the Halloween
Heist you'll be handcuffed to your
partner so what prize are we playing for
you ask say hello to the infinitude
gobler whoever possesses these stones at
midnight will be named Champion hey best
friend bill will hide the gems in his
pocket I rigged the envelopes so that we
could team up I wanted Jake to rig the
envelopes and partner up with
Hol I'm sorry someone's making a move
that's right that someone is US was that
the gems did you drop
them I've been training cheddar to
retrieve gems I know you swallowed them
you swallowed the gems wait until
cheddar passes the gems and then we
restart the heist the next time we all
have a free day perfect when will that
be let the heist re begin flers from
Bill H whoa whoa whoa whoa this is a
scam there's no one in Bill's life that
would send him flowers protect Bill
protect the gems can't see anything
there's too many of them the gems are
gone I saw you brush up against one of
the flower delivery men who handed you
the gems which you gave to Scully who
placed them in his mouth yep he
swallowed the heist re re begin okay in
5 minutes 10 other bunnies will March
past this door we'll blend in and grab
the gems get ready bunnies are going to
be here at any moment someone got the
fanny pack they're headed for the roof
go go go go go
[Music]
go what's up losers spent every morning
for the last year giving cheddar a taste
for ham the second part of my plan took
place on Valentine's Day which went
perfectly I marked the gems with ham
again and everything pushed to Easter
when I could finally get rid of Scully
as my partner I grabbed the gems jumped
off the roof wrote my name in Flames
wait why did you keep delaying the
heists couldn't you have just wanted
Halloween oh I did these are the real
Halloween gems I switched them out
before cheddar found them I also won on
Valentine's Day what is happening switch
those gems out before I gave them to
Scully and then I won today so while you
nerds are always arguing about who the
only two-time Champion is me I just
became the first three time Champion I
guess there's just one thing left to do
to Roa Diaz an amazing human SL genius
Rosa Diaz it's me Captain Holt it's
Heist day Jake
oh I'm leaving the 99 The Heist is
actually going to be the perfect goodbye
for the final heist we will all be
competing for this there's going to be a
huge fireworks display no fireworks okay
[Applause]
fineing at the car I'm very responsible
Terry Terry Terry it's Jake and the
squad calling from your butt Kevin's
human head on Cheddar's dog
body surprise Reve this is a fake office
it's all part of the
heist that was
crazy hey there Ray Ray no no no no
no don't you stick around
okay stick around was another magnet pun
yeah I get it was a pun nice work I
almost feel so bad that I have to betray
you let's ride bye in order for this to
work we have to get to the golden Tube
before Holt does and swap it out for the
one with a tie
inside hey there Ray Ray then with Rosa
believing that Holt has the real one you
just need to come up with a fake Heist
and then find a way to slip her the
dummy tube it went perfectly the perfect
goodbye is so close I can taste it are
you quitting the 99 Charles I can
explain don't bother Charles found out I
was leaving somehow and he got so upset
that he ran away I know exactly where he
is here guard this with your life I'll
be right back another surprise reveal
nikolaj nikolaj nikolaj nikolaj nikolaj
nikolaj why don't you just call him Nick
ne all right now you're ruining the
moment we're fancy B us you're cutting
me out this is about you wanting
fireworks isn't it it's 1 million per
just about the fireworks those look very
dangerous Oh no you're awake you
replaced me with
Teddy what
give me the two I don't have someone
else has it I know this place yes this
is where we worked our first case with
Captain Holt that's right it's a
meaningful location tonight is my
victory lab I plan the perfect goodbye
you have got to be kidding me we're
trapped pardon me excuse me did you say
we're trapped who the hell are you you
don't recognize Carolyn St jacqu Renard
not now Carolyn St jacqu Renard I agree
with Jeff it's read the room kin St Jack
reard oh yeah right I got on the
GPS huh that's weird what where'd he go
are you sure he came back to the
precinct the tracker must be broken
there's no one here wrong
Captain I'm here Michael Hitchcock the
grand champion of the 99 but I never
really retired or moved to Brazil I've
been living in the beaver trap this
whole time okay but what was the rest of
the plan oh we had not come up with it
but then bill came by and offered to
sell me the tube for 40 bucks and I won
pretty good stuff Michael Hitchcock you
are an amazing human SL genius and the
grand champion of the
99 why is your head so sweaty well
because that's actually butt skin from a
botched hair transplant so there're more
pores I can't believe this is how it
ends